- [Voiceover] Hello everyone.
So now that we have an intuition
for what divergence is
trying to represent,
let's start actually
drilling in on a formula.
The first thing I want to do
is just limit our perspective to functions
that only have an X component, or rather,
where the Y component of
the output is just zero.
So this is some kind of vector field
and if there's only an X component
what this means it's going to look like
is all of the vectors
only go left or right,
and there's kind of no up or
down involved in any of them.
So in this case, let's
start thinking about what
positive divergence of your vector fields
might look like near some point X-Y.
So if you have your point,
this is that point X-Y sitting
off somewhere in space,
two cases where the divergence
of this might look positive
are, one, where nothing
happens at the point.
So in this case P would be
equal to zero at our point.
But then to left of it things
are moving to the left,
meaning P, the X component of
our vector valued function,
is negative.
That's why the X component
of this vector is negative.
But then to the right,
vectors would be moving off to the right.
So over here, P would be positive.
So this would be an example of a
positive divergence circumstance
where only the X component is responsible.
And what you'll notice here,
this would be P starts negative,
goes zero, then becomes positive.
So as you're changing in the X direction,
P should be increasing.
So a positive divergence
here seems to correspond to
a positive partial derivative
of P with respect to X.
And if that seems a little unfamiliar,
if you're not sure how to
think about partial derivatives
of a component of a vector field,
I have a video on that
and you can take a look
and refresh yourself, how
you might think about this
partial derivative of P with respect to X.
And once you do, hopefully it makes sense
why this specific positive
divergence example
corresponds with the positive
partial derivative of P.
But remember, this isn't the only way
that a positive divergence might look.
You're gonna have another
circumstance where, let's say,
your point, X-Y,
actually has a vector attached to it.
So this here again
represents our point X-Y.
And in this specific example
this would be P is positive.
P of X-Y is positive at your point there.
But another way that positive
divergence might look
is that you have things
coming in towards that point
and things going away,
but the things going away
are bigger than the ones coming in.
But again, this exhibits the
idea of P increasing in value.
P starts off small, it's a
positive but small component,
and then it gets bigger and
then it gets even bigger.
So once again we have this idea of
positive partial derivative
of P with respect to X,
because changes in X,
as you increase X it
causes an increase in P,
seems to correspond to
positive divergence.
And you can even look at
it if you go the other way
where you have a little bit of
negative component to P here.
So P is a little bit negative,
but to the left of your
point it's really negative,
and then to the right it's
not nearly as negative.
And in this case it's kind of like
as you're moving to the
right, as X is increasing,
you start off very negative,
and then only kind of negative,
and then barely negative.
And once again that
corresponds to an increase
in the value of P as X increases.
So what you'd expect is that
a partial derivative of P,
that X component of the
output, with respect to X,
is gonna be somewhere
involved in the formula
for the divergence of our
vector field at a point X-Y.
In the next video I'm gonna
go a similar line of reasoning
to see what should go on
with that Y component.